So let's take a look at the types of partners.
One of the most interesting concepts is strategic alliances.
One of the concepts in start-ups that is important to remember
is this idea of the whole product.
It turns out there is no possible way on day 1
that your start-up could provide a mainstream customer
with a complete solution; you just can't.
You don't have enough time or money or resources
to fill out every possible thing someone in a Fortune-1000 company
is going to put on a checklist or an RFP for you to provide.
So the idea is to use strategic alliances
to complement your core product with other products or services.
It could be training, could be installation, could be service,
that is to surround your product with a cloud of other resources
to address mainstream customers.
For example, in 1996 Starbucks® partnered with Pepsi™
to bottle, distribute, and sell Frappuccino®,
which gave them access to Pepsi's™ enormous distribution channel.
Now, one word of caution.
You understand that the phrase I used was to develop the whole product,
to deliver a complete solution to mainstream customers.
The mistake start-ups often make is thinking
that they're selling to mainstream customers the day they first ship.
It turns out that for most start-ups not in an existing market,
you're not selling to mainstream customers,
you're selling to crazy people just like you.
It turns out that those people, which we called earlyvangelists,
are more than happy to assemble the complete solution themselves,
so all the bus-dev activities that start-ups scramble to get ready
by first customer ship actually could be deferred in most ventures
to actually after you got those first earlyvangelist customers
because it's the earlyvangelists who will, once they build the product themselves,
actually tell you what the complete feature set is.
So, think about strategic alliances.
Don't just checklist "I need a head of bus-dev
and all these solutions on day 1."
Think about what order they come in.